letzten Sommer waren mein Team und ich
für acht Tage in der Türkei unterwegs
und die Videos die wir dort gedreht
haben die habt ihr schon gesehen heute
zeigen wir euch aber was alles hinter
den Kulissen passiert ist
bevor die Reise aber losgehen kann muss
mein Team erstmal zu uns finden also
hier ist der Türkei Vlog 22 mit
Aufnahmen die wir euch nicht
vorenthalten wollen meine Frau ist auch
dabei ganz vergessen
[Musik]
zu diesem Zeitpunkt konnte Annas nicht
lassen und sie Kamera ins Gesicht zu
halten Sally war noch nicht da weswegen
wir erstmal hinhalten mussten
[Musik]
jetzt kommt noch besser werden
die Welt ich bin gern unterwegs und
entdeckt ist für mich so
aber
jetzt gehen wir gleich lecker Essen der
Mistelbach
freut ihr euch auf den ganzen Knoblauch
[Applaus]
Murat weiß es noch gar nicht aber er
wird in diesem Block auch Reiseführer
sein und das fängt jetzt direkt
nicht aber du wirst Reiseführer in
diesem Block also ich bin hier der der
Reiseführer in diesem Block und ich
werde die Reise führen also folgt mir
einen anderen Auto ich glaube das ist
ich war glaube ich in einem anderen Auto
warum
Puma
käfiguren
los geht's
so herzlich willkommen bei Murat
Traumreisen und damit diese Traumreise
keine albtraumreise wird müssen wir uns
ein gewisse Regeln halten so der
Präsident wird nicht beleidigt erstmal
vorneweg so
danke schön
herzlich willkommen in der Türkei wir
sind hier in kaiseri und zwar ist
Kaiserin sozusagen
das Schwabenland der Türkei hier ist ein
lauter geschäftstüchtige Menschen und äh
hier ist auch das größte Industriegebiet
der Türkei
danke schön
schön dass wir alle da sind an was
müssen wir uns halten ihr könnt
eigentlich
ja ich freue mich ganz ganz besonders
ach so meine Frau ist auch dabei
Entschuldigung vergessen
[Musik]
ich bin nur die Dekoration hier
und wir machen jetzt den ganz ganz tolle
Reise durch die Türkei eigentlich quer
durch wir werden verschiedene
Produzenten besuchen und euch zeigen wie
verschiedene Dinge auch hergestellt
werden die Menschen dahinter die
Menschen hinter den ganzen Produkten
hinter den ganzen Ideen die wir haben
und ja es wird eine ganz ganz tolle
Reise und wir freuen uns richtig drauf
ich bin Murat ich bin der meine Aufgabe
ich finde Reiseführer und ähm ich werde
wie soll ich sagen ja ab und zu dabei
sein
ich wollte euch eigentlich was erzählen
aber ich bin so müde
eigentlich wisst ihr das Wichtigste
schon über Kaiserin hier gibt es Mantel
hier gibt es Sucuk und hier gibt es
Pasta
und es gibt Baklava
[Musik]
also erster Furz Stock hier in Karlsruhe
sind wir jetzt beim Grill und zwar habt
ihr ganz viele Vorspeisen zum Beispiel
geschmorte Zwiebeln mit
Tomatensalat mit Walnüssen wir haben
hier so eine Tomaten Paprika Salat
natürlich
essen ja
also Kaiser ist für viele Speisen
bekannt vor allem die Wurstwaren und die
Fleischwaren und hier haben wir zum
Beispiel pastrami und zwar pastrami das
ist wie gesagt Schinken richtig lecker
der wird mit boxerklärung umrandet es
ist Trockenfleisch richtig lecker
und es schmeckt richtig würzig es war
absolute Hammer dafür ist Kaiser sehr
bekannt ich habe das mal mitgenommen ich
habe das mal aus Kaiserin nach
Deutschland mitgenommen und dann haben
sie mir am Ding abgenommen am Zoll ja
leider
[Musik]
dass man mehrere Speisen auf Tellern
hatten dass man alle von den gleichen
Tellern ist also man hat zwar einen
eigenen Teller aber über einen Spaniern
die ganzen Tapas ist in der Türkei
wirklich so wenn alles aufgetischt und
man greift dann einfach rein das ist so
ein gesellschaftliches Essen
Region bekannt in Italien genauso in
Spanien ganz extrem
[Musik]
morgen morgen
nicht
gestellt aber sind wir motiviert
[Musik]
gucken mal hier gibt's nämlich Rafting
also falls ihr mal hier Urlaub machen
wollt
Urlaub hier ist auch ganz cool denn da
gibt's so eine rafting-welt mit so
kleinen Zelten und da kann man was
richtig tolles erleben kann
[Musik]
unser erster Stopp hier ist in checkerek
in yours-guard und zwar ist es die
provinzius grad die klimatisch gesehen
aber schon ein bisschen mehr ans
Schwarze Meer erinnert und wir sind
jetzt hier gerade an einer richtig
historischen Wassermühle hier wird
nämlich Mehl gemalt und zwar ist es so
ein urweizen den man hier noch anbaut
der ist wirklich schon Jahrtausende alt
und der ist ganz ganz toll weil er
biologisch angebaut wird nicht gehen in
manipuliert wurde und einfach noch ganz
natürlich ist und die Frauen da hinten
wie ihr seht sie wahrscheinlich schon im
Hintergrund die sind alle ganz
traditionell angezogen und die haben ja
auch so ein ganz ganz tolles
sieverfahren erstellt für die Frauen
damit Sie es einfach bei der Arbeit so
ein bisschen einfacher haben um
Vollkornmehl herzustellen und um eben
auch Mehl herzustellen was ein bisschen
weniger vollkommen beinhaltet die machen
jeden Tag zwei Tonnen mehr
die haben 35 Säcke a 50 Kilo jeden Tag
wunderbar
durch die Wasserkraft angetrieben wird
einfach nur Wassermühle
die machen hier Marmelade die machen
Honig die die Stellen keiner kehrt die
Stellen wirklich alles her wir haben
jetzt auch gleich so ein geniales
Frühstück das hatten wir jetzt gerade
schon und ihr lernt jetzt hier gleich
alle Menschen kennen ist eine richtig
tolle Gemeinde also kommt mit rein
[Musik]
also ich muss sagen checke Weg gefällt
mir richtig gut Joska ist eine ganz ganz
tolle Provinz und hier hinter mir das
seht ihr ein großes Gebäude und zwar ist
es das ist ein Zentrum wo man als
erwachsener Hund als Kind oder Teenager
wo wirklich jeder Altersgruppe rein kann
und was erleben kann so ein science
Labor sozusagen da gibt's bisschen
Chemie bisschen Physik Wissenswertes und
gerade wenn es draußen sehr sehr heiß
ist ist ja ganz gut wenn man indoor eben
auch Beschäftigungen hat und das finde
ich hier richtig gut und weiter da vorne
direkt da über die Brüstung sehe ich
jetzt schon unser Lavendelfeld das sieht
richtig toll aus komm wir gehen mal auf
den aufsichtspunkt
[Musik]
schneller Tolga renn renn renn renn renn
renn renn renn renn Rennen
bin ich richtig in der Annahme das ist
auf der Insel keine Toilette hat
ja
wir gehen jetzt zu denen
[Musik]
seid ihr bereit fürs Lavendelfeld okay
ja herzlich willkommen in yozguard wir
sind jetzt hier gerade auf einer Insel
und zwar ist es die lavendelinsel was
wir genau machen erfahrt ihr gleich
jetzt gehen wir erstmal hoch kommt
[Musik]
ja wir sind jetzt hier weil ich euch
unsere neue Kosmetik vorstellen möchte
da sind wir auf die Idee gekommen weil
wir uns gedacht haben wir könnten doch
unser Rosenöl unser Rosenwasser
verbinden mit unserem Olivenöl was eben
auch richtig toll für die Haut ist und
haben dann gedacht dass wir nicht nur
Rose verwenden sondern eben auch orange
hoch seht ihr jetzt kommt der schon eine
ganze Wind eben auch orange und auch
Lavendel und weil wir gerade hier in
ihre sind jetzt ist nämlich gerade
august und die lavendelzeit ist jetzt im
vollen Gange sind wir hier auf den
Lavendelfelder und werden gemeinsam
jetzt erstmal Lavendel ernten später
destillieren und dann stellen wir unsere
eigene Creme her und das zeige ich euch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
6 Jahre alt hast du schon Augenringe
nein
[Musik]
so wir sind hier in yozga im
Forstministerium und zwar das ist ein
Gebäude mitten im Wald und hier sind wir
eingeladen worden zum Essen
[Musik]
ja jetzt sind wir in einen Jack und zwar
ist es in der Nähe von joschgarten
dieser Ort hat 3000 Einwohner und ist
bekannt für sein Kunsthandwerk und das
hier ist das Kulturhaus in einen Jack
das heißt es ist Kulturhaus hier wird
alles rund um die in die Region josgat
wird hier gezeigt die ganze Kultur die
ganze Kunst dahinter und jetzt gehen wir
kurz rein und gucken mal kurz was die
Frauen alles herstellen und uns
vorbereitet haben geht's euch gut ich
Film ja aber egal kein Problem könnt
ruhig schreien
so steinreiches was anderes aber hier
sind lauter Steine die verschiedenen
Aussehen verschiedene Mineralien sind
verschiedenes Gestein und ich habe da
gar keine Ahnung ich habe von Esoterik
auch keine Ahnung aber es gibt zwei
grünen Steine die sollen einen beruhigen
meine Frau hat mir schon zweimal Hals
gehangen und dann gibt's noch die Steine
äh die lilanensteine hier z.B die sollen
einen von negativer Energie fernhalten
das heißt ich habe jetzt für Günni extra
einen Helm äh produzieren lassen die
mich hin aus der Türkei mitbringen guck
mal ist auch cool aus WoW
so und die sind nicht mal teuer also
wenn ich die vergleichen was wir uns äh
Kosten ein bisschen in Deutschland sind
ist nicht der Wahnsinn aber echt cool
muss ich ehrlich sagen man ist auch
schön
so alle negativen Vibes gehen jetzt weg
von dir
ich sag's euch Murat wir machen neues
Geschäftsmodell der teenager-stein das
sage ich nicht wegen dir ich sag's nur
wegen Teenager die vielleicht eine
hormonüberfluss haben und die hormonell
bedingt so ein bisschen die Eltern
vielleicht bisschen Nerven und dann kann
man so ein teenager-stein machen der
dann funktioniert
weil unser Kind ist nicht so aber es
gibt nur so
Hormone Regeln negative Energie Weg
Erfolg und dann zack Erfolgsrezept
[Musik]
hier machen sie so ganze Pokale und
Dekoartikel aber die machen sie wirklich
selber also das was wir denken das kommt
immer aus Fernost wird wirklich hier per
Hand gemacht und zwar mit dem gleichen
Werkzeug wie du bei Torten bei dem
Motivtorten hast gucken der ritzt es so
rein und das ist dann nicht das was
verkauft wird sondern daraus wird so
eine silikonmall darstellt und daraus
werden dann die für die Massenproduktion
gemacht also dann kann man quasi starten
und das Ganze eben dafür machen also die
machen so so Wahrzeichen sei Kunst oder
oder wie auch immer die machen sie
plastisch hier und die werden dann in
diesen ganzen Dekoartikel Leben verkauft
damit die Touristen eben auch so ein
bisschen Stück weit Geschichte
mitbekommen
die ganzen Touristen Hochburgen und dann
in irgendwelchen Zeiten und zu verkaufen
ist auch richtig cool aus
jetzt haben wir uns den ganzen Schmuck
angeschaut richtig tolle Handarbeit die
sie dort machen einiges auch gekauft für
uns und unsere Freunde und jetzt zeige
ich euch wie der Schmuck hergestellt
wird ich habe
den müssen wir am besten der sorgt
nämlich auch dafür dass man gut schlafen
kann und runter kommt negative Energie
los wird am besten nehmen wir den mit
den packe ich in dein Kopfkissen und das
ist das was Sie hier in eidenchip bei
jostgut abbauen das ist die Mineralien
das ist ganz krass und die klopfen das
da wirklich da raus und machen Ihren
Schmuck raus ja komm
Steine
Stein
Mineralien wow
die ganze Zeit zu gehen
komm mach einfach
[Musik]
ist hier sozusagen die Direktorin von
allem und wir haben uns jetzt gerade
gemeinsam überlegt dass ich mir ein
Stein aussuchen darf und eine Kette
Hersteller und die Verluste von euch
Erfolgs Stein den gibt es dann für euch
heute wieder mit Schürze aber nicht in
der Küche
[Musik]
selber machen
also jetzt hier keine Sorge der
steinschneider ist nicht scharf deswegen
darf ich mit dem bloßen Fingern rein und
wir schneiden das mit Öl damit das ganze
nicht zu heiß wird und einfach
geschmeidig durchgehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also jetzt haben wir den einmal klein
geschnitten und der wird jetzt schön
poliert
[Musik]
ich habe auch ein Stein gemacht das ist
schon ganz schön schwierig weil es halt
sage ich mal wie so ein Schleifstein ist
und man kann sich da schon ein verletzen
aber ich habe aufgepasst und die haben
mir auch geholfen die Frauen die das
hier machen und
man unterschätzt immer wie schwierig
oder wie leicht es ist weil es schon
ziemlich schwierig
[Musik]
neues Mikrofon Stativ und das haben die
Frauen gemacht
die sind ein bisschen erfahrener als ich
und die machen dann auch wirklich bei
diesem Schleifstein sage ich mal die
machen halt die Nägel zu nah dran und
ist schon ganz schön gefährlich weil man
kann sich da schon die Haut
abrubbeln sage ich mal abschleifen ja
und danke schön auch an Ella an meinen
Stativ und mein Mikrofon Stativ gell sag
mal was
ja
unsere Produktdesignerin und die haben
auch extra wirklich auch mitgenommen
dass die Karo mal was anderes sieht und
vor allem auch mal sieht wie Sachen
hergestellt und produziert werden und es
soll eine Karo ist dass du selber
Schmuck machst gell ja sie macht selber
schmucken kennt sie eigentlich schon aus
und sie ist zum ersten mal hier oder
nicht zum ersten Mal und sehr
beeindruckt also was hier alles gemacht
wird und wie es gemacht wird mit sehr
viel Handarbeit und ja man lernt immer
auf Reisen nicht in Schulen das ist das
wichtige so reisen wir und haben dann
einfach neue Impressionen neue Ideen und
die wir dann verwirklichen können
[Musik]
nur eine Chance ich muss jetzt passen
jetzt kommt der Anhänger dran das Loch
haben wir jetzt hier schön getrocknet
jetzt schaue ich mal das muss natürlich
noch gekürzt werden
ja so sieht's gut aus
da ist sie meine Kette für euch danke
tschüss
okay was hast Du getan
für mich und meine Freundin
was hast du gemacht ich habe das gemacht
werden also so ein Kette und das auch
aber die Maschine war schon zu deswegen
konnte
okay
[Musik]
was machst du da bist
sicher
auf türkisch heißt danke schön
[Musik]
wir hatten jetzt hier zwei Tage richtig
anstrengenden Dreh auf dem Lavendelfeld
mit unserem Team und das ganze Team hier
vor Ort die Frauen und Männer sind so
lieb jetzt haben sie so ein richtig
großes Abendessen gekocht eigentlich
haben wir gesagt es reicht auch Salat
wir essen einfach nur Salat und Suppe
und jetzt haben wir richtig schön Abend
gegessen wir werden hier richtig
bewertet und sind ganz herzlich
willkommen das ist richtig schön hier
also falls ihr seid wirklich kommt hier
unbedingt mal her so schön hier
jetzt gleich mal Nachtisch
gerade der Bürgermeister spricht gerade
vorne mit Murat und er lobt die ganzen
Frauen er sagte die ganzen Frauen hier
stemmen das alles und sorgen dafür dass
sie gearbeitet wird und die Arbeit und
diese richtige ganze Arbeit richtig
schön ich meinte können sich jetzt auch
einfach mit den Fehlern anderer
schmücken aber das macht dann doch nach
vorne
gegangen
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
bekam auch jeder vom Team ein kleines
Geschenk von Bürgermeister worüber wir
uns alle gefreut haben ich habe den
fokussten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Tasche für Schuhe Tasche für die overall
Tasche für die Einteiler oder
[Musik]
oh nein
richtig schön da gibt's ganz tolle
Sachen die die Menschen hier selber
machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich glaube ich brauche News
okay ich gehe jetzt Eis essen Leute Ich
werde dich richtig
[Musik]
Waffel der Welt
er fragt mich gerade ob ich Eis essen
will und dann noch Waffeln und in einer
Stunde essen gehen will ich verstehe die
Frage nicht mehr hallo kleiner Bär
[Musik]
schmeckt gut schmeckt wirklich gut ich
habe Pistazien
Pistazie mit Himbeeren Schokoglasur und
Haselnüsse
und jetzt gibt es noch eine Waffe kommt
du stehst schon an
ich warte drauf
ist
eine Waffe für alle mit pistaziencreme
okay und Erdbeeren und Schokosoße und
keine Ahnung ich übrigens einer der
bekanntesten waffelläden in
bekannteste sein hier ist über eine
Schlange
hier nur noch Instagram und Facebook und
wie auch immer ich bin natürlich keiner
ich stelle mich trotzdem an
du bist doch nicht mal mit deinem
Eisbären
ich bin ja auch hier ein Foodblogger
ich bin Foodblogger auf Mission da darf
man alles probieren und mach Mut macht
schon Zeichen der sagt schon ist ganz
wenig denn wir gehen jetzt essen wir
gehen gleich
[Musik]
das ist ähm
hatten wir auch schon bei Netflix
gesehen der hat dort bei Chef's table
mitgemacht und ist auch richtig lecker
sein da gehen deswegen darf ich
eigentlich aufessen
[Musik]
Schokolade Krokant und da war irgendwas
drauf ich weiß nicht was es ist
boah
hey hol mal kurz Ding hey probiert das
mal bitte hey Hammer
aber wir haben das schönere Fahrt
zusammen spielen da bist du nur beim
Hinschauen
[Musik]
das sind die kirschglocken hier in
Istanbul ich habe nämlich nicht nur
Moscheen sondern auch Kirchen Synagogen
hier sind alle Weltreligionen vereint
und alle vertreten
[Musik]
irgendetwas war ungewiss vor wenigen
Minuten lief ich noch mit meinem Partner
durch die Straßen der Stadt doch auf
einmal verschwand er okay wo sind die
hier also machte ich mich auf die Suche
auf wie viele Katzen an diesem Ort
lebten doch der kleine Mann mein Mann
war nirgends aufzufinden
[Musik]
okay zugegeben manchmal ließ ich mich
auch von den süßen Mädchen ablenken
ich war gerade am aufgeben als ich ihn
sah er war gefangen im Schilderwald
Ronja Antalya
Riese ist mir
istanbul ist die Tücher hallo
[Musik]
auf der Straße zu essen aber da ist
alles voll deswegen gehen wir mal rein
klimatisiert
wir sind direkt vom Flugzeug sozusagen
in die Großstadt Istanbul waren jetzt in
Moorburg
guten Appetit heute ist Tag für unsere
Türkei Reise und wir sind alle noch hoch
motiviert und freuen uns das
Abendprogramm denn ich muss sagen das
beste Essen auf der Welt soweit ich das
beurteilen kann ist das türkische essen
wir sind jetzt wohl genervt schlafen
noch bisschen durch die Stadt heute ist
richtig viel los in heute ist ein
Fußballspiel von Fenerbahce ich habe
schon gesagt
und sagt
aber dann werden
die türkischen Fußballfans die sind
schon
mal sagen
wir jetzt unser Team wieder eingeholt
und ich finde ist auch richtig schön
einfach eine schöne Stadt
[Musik]
cool gell
mit Honig drauf
ist voll lecker
[Musik]
morgen kaufen
doch morgen sind wir auch noch mal
unterwegs die sind jetzt alle Weg ganz
schnell Sam
eigentlich
sind so süß
soll ich mir auch eine kaufen
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
Murat hat natürlich wieder was zum
Shoppen von Wasser gefunden
wir sind Dollar Schein
mein Kind
YouTube und der ist aber Ella ich kann
bei dir reinhängen
was willst du dann damit machen
angucken
anschauen okay und dann will ich von der
reichen Zukunft träumen echt was ich mal
dein Ziel in deinem Leben
aber kriege ich irgendwann eine
Monobraue
keine Ahnung
kriegst du okay
guten Morgen aus der schönsten Stadt der
Welt wir sind in Istanbul
gerade angehobbt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ja und hier hinter uns Brücke und da
gehen wir jetzt direkt frühstücken im
locker und zwar gibt's da verschiedene
Frühstückscafés aber wir müssen das
ausgesucht jetzt gucken wir mal was ist
dafür schönes Frühstück gibt
[Musik]
guten Appetit auf Wiedersehen
wir sind hier gerade mit Mahmut zusammen
in Berg
Mahmut ist unser Reiseführer
touristführer
Touristen touristikbeauftragter und wir
laufen jetzt mit ihm durchs Bett gehen
später in der Konditorei und erleben mit
ihm gemeinsam ganz viele Istanbul ihr
kennt ihn ja schon aus unserem Olivenöl
Videos unser Mann fürs Olivenöl
natürlich und wir haben immer sehr viel
Spaß zusammen
[Musik]
synchron also du nimmst dann die
Audiospur extrahierschte vom Video und
dann tust Du quasi die Audiospur auf
deine Videospur danke und das
Synchronisieren hilft dir dabei dass du
den Punkt findest und jetzt nicht
unbedingt Millimeter für mm gucken muss
zweite Ausbildungsjahr
gehört sogar
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir hier in der ältesten
Konditorei Istanbuls die wurde 1923
gegründet also genau in dem Jahr in dem
auch die Republik Türkei gegründet wurde
also der Chef hier der Patissier der hat
damals in Frankreich gelernt bei ganz
berühmten Konditoren kam dann quasi in
die Türkei wieder zurück als die Türkei
die Republik wurde und hat jetzt hier so
mit seiner eigenen Handschrift die
eigene türkisch französische Konditorei
entwickelt
dann probieren wir mal
[Musik]
also hier haben wir zum Beispiel einen
San Sebastian Cheesecake der kostet ein
Stück 100 Lira und ein ganzer Kuchen 470
Lira 5 Euro kostet ein Stück von
Sebastian Cheesecake ist schon Luxus
hier für die Türkei ungefähr der
Grundlohn in Türkei liegt bei ungefähr
momentan bei 5000 türkische Lira und bin
ich überlege das so ein Kuchen äh fast
500 kostet 10% eines Grundlohnes was man
hier für eine Torte bezahlt das heißt
wenn äh jemand 3000 brutto verdienen 300
sieht schon alles verdammt gut aus aber
ist nichts drin
also nehmen wir auch nur ein kleines
Stück
für alles 16
[Musik]
okay also für euch haben uns gedacht
können wir uns jetzt mal vier Stück
Kuchen wir haben uns dann Sebastian cake
einen Macaron mit Erdbeeren einen
Raphael und ein Mini Pavlova das
probieren wir jetzt mal und ich finde
allein die Aussicht lohnt sich halt
schon also wenn ihr mal hier seid dann
trinkt gerne auch einfach nur einen
Eisplatte oder einen Tee und genießt die
aus und probierten Stückchen
[Musik]
aber geschmacklich gut
aber falls ihr nicht nach Istanbul
Reisen könnt macht gerne mein Rezept
[Musik]
so wir schippern hier gerade auf dem
Bosporus und zwar unten am Hafen kann
man sich Bote mit je nach Größe
variieren die Preise zwischen 100 und
200 Euro wir sind jetzt mit dem Team
hier auf dem Boot und schippern hier
wirklich durch die Bosporus Meerenge
zwischen zwei Kontinenten auf der einen
Seite der asiatische Teil von Istanbul
auf der anderen Seite europäische Teil
man sieht hier ganz ganz viele tolle
alte Häuser und auch geschichtsträchtige
Bauten ist echt ganz ganz toll aus aber
es ist wirklich wunderschön wenn
Istanbul erleben möchte dann muss man
auf dem Boss Brust mal drüber fahren mit
dem Schiff man kann es auch günstiger
machen da gibt's viele Ferien
durchfahren die Kosten dann teilweise
nur zwei drei Euro aber hier sind wir
jetzt eine Community mit 13 14 Leuten
auf dem Boden und können einfach das
Land und auch das Wetter genießen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der Plan ist jetzt dass wir mitten auf
dem wie heißt der wie heißt der
Bruder wie heißt das hier
wie heißt das denn
zur Türkei Istanbul okay wir versuchen
jetzt die Drohne mitten auf dem Bosporus
zu starten
ähm vielleicht wird sie abgeschossen
vielleicht nicht vielleicht wenn auch
ich abgeschossen funktioniert natürlich
ich bin immer das klassische
funktionierte außerdem ist die Anna
Profi
[Musik]
so schön
die Sonne die Stimmung oh mir geht's
auch wieder besser ich habe nämlich die
letzten 5 Stunden auf dem Boden nicht
hingelegt weil ich echt
üble da Probleme habe ich sag's euch
wissen
ich kann nur vermutlich die nächsten
fünf Tage nichts essen aber alles gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dann heißt wir sind Feinde du versteckst
dich dann ja
verstanden
[Musik]
leider schon unser letzter Abend in
Istanbul morgen reißen wir wieder ab
morgen geht's nach isnik da werden wir
neue keramikflaschen herstellen und
jetzt genießen wir unser hoffentlich
richtig leckeres Essen hier direkt los
okay
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt von Istanbul eine Stunde
dreiviertel Stunde gefahren
und sind jetzt hier an einem
frühstücksort wir haben meist eigentlich
keinen Frühstück im Hotel mal was gesagt
haben wir frühstücken unterwegs weil wir
echt früh aufstehen also so für euch
vielleicht mal weil alle denken in
unseren Stories sieht immer alles so
voll idyllisch aus und wer ist voll die
Reise also unsere Tage fangen morgens an
zwischen 6 und 6:30 Uhr bis ich dann
nämlich geduscht und fertig bin und ich
bin immer noch nicht geschminkt weil es
mir zu früh war Kinder fertig packen
dann geh mal raus meistens check out so
um 8 Uhr im Hotel
und dann fahren wir so zwei drei Stunden
dann die nächste Location unterwegs
frühstücken wir dann wird den ganzen Tag
gedreht fotografiert Videos alles
ähm dann wird am Abend noch gegessen
meistens dann auch erst abends später um
8:30 Uhr 9 Uhr bis wir dann wieder im
Auto sind im Hotel sind an der nächsten
Location sind ist dann irgendwie so
23:30 Uhr das heißt wir gehen mit sechs
Stunden schlafen
aber es ist schön und dann versuchen die
meisten im Auto zu schlafen oder wir
verrückten Anna guckt dann immer schon
Material durch wie wir schneidet dann
schon Reals Holger macht Yvonne alle
alle sind kreativ die können einfach
nicht aufhören aber jetzt frühstücken
wir hier gibt's Männer das ist das
türkische Rührei mit Tomate richtig
lecker und ich hoffe ich hoffe so selbst
mit viel Käse
und jetzt meine Mama
machen nur Tomate gar nichts probieren
[Musik]
1 2 3
er zieht sich nicht
es hat kein gasekäse
[Musik]
wo fahren wir hin
ist nichts ist eine keramikflasche
Herstellung
[Musik]
ach so meinst du die bleibt die ganze
Zeit im Background hocken so wie machen
nein das klappt nur bei Muffin
wir müssen dahin und dahinter
und diese Tüte da müssen wir noch grün
[Musik]
für die Atmosphäre oder
[Applaus]
okay Anfang haben wir gemacht Gott ihr
wisst ja wir stellen ja seit zwei Jahren
hier diese handgemachten keramikflaschen
hier in Isny care und zwar sind die vom
Design her richtig schön wir haben ganz
viele tolle verschiedene Farben von
Rainbow über einfarbig über
Pinselmalerei bis hin zu diesen Streifen
aber natürlich haben wir uns gedacht wir
möchten auch was Neues erschaffen
deswegen haben wir uns eine neue Form
überlegt eine schöne Runde bauchige Form
[Musik]
ich könnte mir nichts besseres
vorstellen hier eine Dreiviertelstunde
zu warten
ich schwöre ich habe auch gearbeitet
ich schwör's ich habe auch gearbeitet
ich habe nicht die ganze Zeit mit der
Katze gekuschelt wirklich
[Musik]
und dann wollte ich mich auch mal dran
probieren
[Musik]
besser als ich
mach mal ein paar Versuche hier ja
ich kann so nicht arbeiten
wir müssen eh noch bisschen auf paar
Rainbows warten aber ja ich übe schon
mal ja ich weiß mein erster Versuch
ich liebe die Rainbow Flasche ich mache
gleich noch eine
[Musik]
regenbogenflaschen sind fertig jetzt
werde ich noch das Auge zeichnen und
Samira wollen auch ein paar Flaschen
malen deswegen mache ich hier ein
bisschen Platz für die Mädels und ich
glaube da kommen richtig kreative
Flaschen zustande aber die sind dann nur
für uns
denn alles andere wäre Kinderarbeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du willst die Laune aufhellen mit einem
Witz des Tages okay
[Musik]
dann gehen sie weiter dann von der eins
zweihundert
[Musik]
3300 sein
auf dem Boden Fritzchen fragt deine Oma
Oma
von dir ein 400 Lehrerin
seine Oma Oma
aufgeben
[Musik]
Fritzchen kannst du dann den mir
aufhelfen dann sagst Fritzchen zu seiner
Oma Oma nein das ist auf der Straße
nicht da wenn ich aufheben
[Musik]
am besten waren die drei und 400
Euroscheine
auch Ella dass du dir so einen langen
Witz merken kannst ey das ist so cool
und ich glaube mit dem Witz des Abends
verabschieden wir uns heute in
Feierabend
das war der Witz dran
[Musik]
ich glaube das erste deutsche Fernsehen
das ARD kommt von hier aus der Türkei
haben sie deutschen von den Türken
geklaut gell wie immer
[Musik]
ganz ehrlich sagen
braucht ihr nicht besuchen also ich
glaube wir frühstücken jetzt kurz dann
gehen wir in das Atelier ich habe es
schon kurz gesehen so eine ganz Mini
kleine Hütte
kann man sich sparen ich glaube wenn man
irgendwo hingeht dann lieber nach aller
Schatzi da ist es schön ist mir das
schön wunderschön aber
ich will euch dann auch etwas erzählen
was nicht ist weil ich meine wenn ich
mich jetzt da hinten umguckt da ist halt
Müllberg alles kaputt und deswegen ja
Lebenszahl wir können am Fluss
frühstücken vor romantisch da kann man
so die Füße ins Wasser strecken und die
Tische stehen im Wasser
kurz hier
bist du Mann
in der Türkei
[Musik]
geh mal frühstücken ja ich weiß nicht wo
die sind ich glaube die sind hinter mir
vorbei
[Musik]
Fokus gezogen gehabt von oben nach unten
vom Hintergrund zum Vordergrund
[Musik]
aber ich finde es immer wichtig dass man
seine Kinder bestärkt in allem was sie
können und dass man sie auch in Dingen
Besteck die Sie vielleicht noch nicht
können aber dort ihre Stärke ausbauen
können ich finde sowas einfach wichtig
und auch zu Hause lasst eure Kinder
einfach mal werkeln und lass sie machen
schafft ihnen halten einen Ort an dem
sie auch mal Sauerei machen dürfen das
bei uns z.B die Garage da darf sie malen
natürlich räumst du danach wieder auf
aber mein Gott wenn da mal was schmutzig
wird oder was kaputt so eine kleine
kreative Ecke im Haus oder draußen auf
der Straße geht den Wald mal bastelt
einfach
vielen Dank bauen oder da drauf machen
aber nicht jeder hatte Pflaster für ihn
aber man kann ja immer auch ins Freie
gehen und künstlerisch Kreativität
[Musik]
die ganze Stadt ist so schön
hübsch okay
okay okay ich Entschuldigung
perfekt
[Musik]
so
wir sind hier in der Türkei
[Musik]
Container aber es ist ein Auto hatte
schon Auto gesehen
passend gemacht für dich sagen also
Steine
okay
Entschuldigung
igung
Schatz
gerissen
hatte ich eigentlich jemand der mal auf
Mekka war also auf der meckerreise in
Heiligenhaus und sagen wir eigentlich
zur Brust
[Musik]
Baustelle die Tür ist gerissen
der
wie sagt man denn da
religiöse der religiöse war auf Mekka
deutsch
okay wir wollten gerade wir wollten
gerade machen
und jetzt haben wir einfach Stromausfall
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schauen unser letzter Abend in der
Türkei mit unserem Team und ich muss
sagen es war für mich wir sind die
schönste Türkei Reise wir haben so viel
erlebt in so kurzer Zeit es war total
familiär mein Team hat gepasst die
Kinder waren dabei
es war alles einfach wunder wunderschön
und wir könnten euch so ein bisschen die
Türkei zeigen ganz viele verschiedene
Orte zeigen und ich hoffe dass ich das
Video gefallen hat ich freue mich schon
wieder auf unsere nächste Türkei Reise
schreibt doch gerne mal in die
Kommentare was euch hier in der Türkei
am besten gefallen hat welcher Ort am
schönsten war ich kann nur eins sagen
weil wir auch gerade hier sind ist
wirklich ein Besuch wert hier gibt's
ganz ganz viele tolle kleine Hotels
richtig schöner Ort ist natürlich ein
bisschen voll aber ihr könnt ja auch ein
bisschen außerhalb kommen das ist
einfach wunderschön die Menschen sind
total positiv richtig leckeres Essen
eine ganz tolle Atmosphäre und es ist
einfach wunderbar es gibt einfach ich
hoffe
bis zum nächsten Mal Kind läuft gerade
dran da muss ich jetzt hin und
[Musik]
es reicht tschüss
überlegt ob ich jetzt noch weiter
moderiere um die Wartezeit zu
überbrücken die mein letztes braucht
aber
sinnlos weil das Leben so lange Nase
angeschaut
aber
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
Ella wie viel Schwestern hat sie denn
so ganz alleine
[Musik]
dann habe ich nichts gesagt Instagram vs
real life
auf alle ja
weil sie wieder Schmuck gesehen hat
ja ja ja genau
und tschüss